the rams took down the seahawks
yesterday you've got a three-way cluster
now at the top of the nfc
west cardinals rams seahawks all
six and three and the rams got it done
yesterday against seattle by virtue of
their defense here's sean mcvay an
offensive coach for a change giving a
ton of credit to his defense
unbelievable job by our defense you know
darius williams with two unbelievably
big picks for us
uh second half the one after the
turnover offensively to be able to get
that play this guy shows up in a big way
i thought jalen ramsey was outstanding
throughout the course of the day didn't
see a lot of action from some of the
guys that he was over the top of and
just our defense as a whole i mean you
just can't say enough about what they've
consistently done doing it against an
offense that's arguably uh producing at
the highest level in the league right
now
every time i see him talk now chris i
think modulation
mod you lation
up and down slow down speed i'm it's as
you said it's always front of the room
teaching the team that's what he's doing
it's always right here he's coaching
reason to be excited yesterday though
taking care of russell wilson and
company my god so so much for the
russell wilson mvp candidacy he went
from getting
none of the votes ever to getting all of
the votes to getting none of the votes
again the way things have gone and the
rams defense has a lot of credit rams
defense shuts down wilson jalen ramsey
shuts down dk metcalf metcalf getting
frustrated yesterday i think the first
time we've ever seen that yeah uh but
but that that's what happens when jaylen
ramsey does his thing that's why that
you pay jalen ramsey 20 million dollars
a year you know and that's why the rams
have star players a little bit it's
games like yesterday their stars made
plays to wrap the game oh leonard freud
free agency three sacks you know of
course aaron donald all around russell
wilson and then the ability to have guys
that can match up against other stars
and that's where jaylen ramsey came in
handy it's what we've been begging for
right i mean i know i've said it on the
podcast we saw it a little bit you know
as far as before the bye week they were
starting to do jaylen ramsey hey you're
on an island you cover that guy the rest
of the defense we're gonna do something
else and they're special when they do
that they have a good formula as far as
the personnel to stop russell wilson and
then when seattle doesn't have chris
carson or any of their running backs it
just becomes all
too much russell wilson he's got to do
everything and that to me is the biggest
issue there let alone we know the
seattle defense is still nothing special
i mean they had their issues but what
we've seen really in all of seattle's
losses this year is yeah russell makes
mistakes because russell has to make
plays constantly to help them win
football games and you know wait chris
you can't you can't when you what you
can't praise dk metcalf incessantly and
then act like russell wilson has no help
whatsoever oh well i'm just talking
about it's always on him and the offense
to make plays it's always on the
quarterback but it's always on no other
mike
tom brady's got 190 yard rusher
yesterday okay you have to have running
games how many defense every week he's
the worst defense in the history of
football mike it's the worst in the
history of football i think you're
exaggerating no no it's statistically
the worst in the history of football
right now it's the worst all right so
how is that counselor will you rush your
case now
okay i oh i just no you just tried to
buy a jerk on us a monday morning you
want to throw that in there yeah okay
great you lost your argument be quiet
can i can i finish please yes i i i have
i have a jiminy cricket in my ear that
is pushing back
on the notion that russell wilson is the
greatest thing as you like to say since
sliced bread right that maybe maybe
russell wilson
isn't
you know
sculpted by god
to be the greatest quarterback of all
time maybe there's a chance that there
are flaws in his abilities and you know
we built this guy up under the notion
that he's underrated it could be that
after building him up and building him
up and building him up and now to the
point where it's less right let russ
cook and it's all on him
maybe he's overrated
maybe we've pushed too far i i i'm not
gonna go too far with that no i i'm not
you know i know ten touchdowns and ten
turnovers in in the last four games hey
yeah and you know i i understand it it's
not great what would you say if your boy
blue did that well i mean i don't know
when my boy blue did it there was a
there was a graph about it every three
minutes and oh that's all we talked
about in football that's all they talked
about look josh allen threw two
interceptions and they lost two games we
got to talk about it because in in the
draft they said he wasn't good and look
now there's two games where he wasn't
good i'm justified i mean with russell
wilson you know again yeah i i'm not
trying to give him a free pass and i
know matt casey's the biggest russell
wilson hater in the world our producer
of the show i'm doing the math just to
see if there's some chance that josh
allen's actually your son i don't know
the eight how the ages were no it
wouldn't it wouldn't work
started real early
you have a very strong affinity for josh
allen as you should but it is funny i
like to tweak you a little bit there but
but russell i mean
look it could just be that when you have
no other help right
well it and and and it starts off in
this magical way where it's russell
russell russell and let russ cook and
every defense that you're facing is
hearing that and seeing that and
breaking it down and if that really is
the strength of the team at some point
nfl caliber defenses are going to come
up with a way to frustrate it to stop it
and to expose it and you're going to
have to go to something else and you
don't have anything else to go to you
know when you take away what you do best
right you fall back to plan b
maybe seattle don't have a plan b so
they stick with plan a even if plan a
isn't working well they've been able to
get away with match-up football at a lot
of these type of moments where oh okay
you know hey they want to put people
down here to maybe stop russell from
throwing or anything like that they've
always been able to rely on
okay at the end of the day wait you're
one on one with dk metcalf we'll go
we'll go to that and that's where it's
an interesting matchup because jalen
ramsey
he is probably i i really think he is
he's the only corner in football i think
that can physically stand in there with
dk metcalf play after play after play i
mean we saw stefan gilmore earlier in
the year he had issues with that
jalen ramsey did not yesterday and then
jalen ramsey hey come on this is one of
the this is one of the freakiest guys
we've seen come in football the last 10
years he is unreal
so his top end speed can match dk
metcalf's too and it's just it's again
you know it's like we've talked about
lamar jackson and any other people like
every team has their kryptonite a little
bit and
this pete carroll and the seattle
seahawks their kryptonite is in la and
it wears yellow and blue i mean they've
lost what five out of the last six
against this football team and the game
they won zeroline missed a pretty
makeable field goal by his standers last
year on a thursday night football game
so because of the playmakers the way
they play and then seattle's defense
still being horrible
hey
they controlled the ball and made enough
plays and it was a fun game but yes
russell made mistakes and he can't
afford to with the way they play this
year
the most glaring mistake when he throws
across his body into the end zone he
sees will dissley he didn't see the
defender the defender had a chance to
jump up and snag the ball again that's
the kind of thing where when you strip
everything away
setting aside that russell is the best
thing they have by far and i'm a huge
russell wilson fan i'm i'm look i'm not
trying to knock the guy you have to call
it like we see it right that's a throw
you don't make you shouldn't make that
throw if you're russell wilson you need
to see that that that defensive player
is there and he has a chance to jump up
and get it and for whatever reason that
was big wilson didn't see him yeah that
was big because that was the moment
where you know let's not forget prior to
that jamal adams had just strip sacked
jared goff so they had just got the ball
back they were down 17-10 being
outplayed and you go man there goes
seattle one of their guys made a play
and here they are even though they're
outplayed and everything like that
they're gonna have a chance to tie the
football game up and i think the thing
that jumped out to us while we watched
it you know one yeah we're not used to
him making those type of mistakes the
guy was open he leaves the pocket a
little bit and he could have probably
ran for 10 to 15 yards if not a
touchdown i mean i think we both agree
with that right he ran up there there
was nobody there there was a guy about
one person 10 yards in front of him
and he decided to throw that out and up
like you said along the sidelines and
then uh of course williams i mean
unbelievable game by him all together
making that interception but that was a
big moment in the football game uh where
seattle had a chance to kind of take
back control of the momentum and control
the game and of course they let that go
and uh they've got to turn it around
quickly now after losing two in a row
now six and three after that great start
uh and and their their their problems
began when they when they faced the
seattle seahawks three weeks ago and
lost that game 37-34
in prime time that was when the bubble
was burst and since then they have not
been a great team and they get a chance
to get on the right track and
we
we've talked about the cardinals the
rams and the seahawks the cardinals and
the rams haven't played each other this
year talk about a great finish they play
each other twice between weeks 13 and
week 17
which is gonna make for a a fascinating
chase for the division title but you
know who who's happiest of all the teams
in the nfc about this it's the green bay
packers
because the packers don't have this that
yeah they play the bears twice
yeah they don't have this yeah right
they don't they've got the clear path to
division title and they can fatten up
their record and they can watch the the
three teams in the nfc west continue to
chew each other up it's amazing well the
packers just sit back and say fine we're
going to be the one seed yeah we're
going to get back we should juggle
against the jaguars
they're going to get the one seed i know
it is it's yeah it's shaping up and it
makes it it makes it even more amazing
that the 49ers emerged with the one seed
last year when you consider
how good those teams are in the nfc west
yeah from seattle to san francisco last
year to the rams and even the cardinals
at 5 10 and 1 were were a tough out last
year the division's even better this
year despite the fact that the 49ers
have kind of faded out of contention
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports